[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم وتقبل الله صومكم وصل انصار
الرئيس المصري المعزول محمد مرسي احتشام
في ميدني رابعه العدويه ونهضه مصر دعما
لما يدعونها الشرعيه فيما دع حمله تمرد
وجبهه الانقاذ الى مظاهرات في ميدان
التحرير ومحيط قصر الاتحاديه للمطالبه
بمحاكمه الرئيس المعزول من جانب اخر
استبعد مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
تواجه مصر خطر تكرار ما دعاها ماساه سوريه
نتوقف مع هذه الاجواء لنناقش من
زاويتين ما هي امكانيه البحث عن تسويه
للازمه السياسيه في مصر في ظل استمرار
الاصرار على اعتماد منطق الحشود
المتبادله
واهداف محادثات مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في القاهره وحدود دور بلاده في
هذه
[موسيقى]
الازمه منطق الحشود المتبادله مازال
مسيطرا على المشهد السياسي في مصر فقد دع
انصار الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي الى
مظاهرات تحت شعار مليونيه الصمود فيما دعا
معارضوه الى مظاهرات مماثله للمطالبه
بمحاكمته
تمضي الايام منذ عزل الرئيس محمد مرسي
وتغييرات ال 30 من يونيو ولا يزال الشارع
السياسي المصري محتقنا خطوات تنفيذ خارطه
المستقبل التي طرحها الجيش مستمره مع جهود
تشكيل الحكومه وتشكيل لجنه تعديل الدستور
ورغم ان المطروح واشتراك جميع الاطياف في
بناء المرحله القادمه في مصر الا ان تحقيق
ذلك يظل صعبا
لارتكاب حدوث تصالح الجميع وهو ما يبدو
بعيدا ح حتى الان الشارع السياسي منقسم
الاخوان المسلمون ومؤيد الرئيس المعزول
يعتبرون ان المعطيات الراهنه لا يمكن ان
تتحقق معها مصالحه وفيهم من يعتقد ان
الخارطه المطروحه مبنيه على اجبارهم على
التسليم بالهزيمه عبر ضغوط مختلفه بينها
اعتقال قادتهم ومحاولات التعتيم الاعلامي
على طرحهم الطرف الاخر معارض الرئيس
المعزول الذين يراهنون لصالح نجاح
المعطيات الراهنه وبمشاركه كل المصريين
الا من عز نفسه لا رجعه للوراء في رايهم
بانتظار نتائج الافرازات الكامله للمرحله
الراهنه دون التعجل بالحكم في غمره هذه
الاجواء يجري الحديث عن وساطات واتصالات
للمصالحه ورغم عدم ورود تفاصيل عن ذلك من
اي جهه فان المصالحه تبقى الاساس الذي
يعبد طريق المرحله القادمه رغم ان ما يحدث
حاليا في الشارع لا ينبئ بحدوث ذلك دون
مخاض عسير في خضم هذا المشهد جرت زياره
نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ويام بيرنس
للقاهره وحذر المسؤول الامريكي مما سماه
بنتائج الاستقطاب بين اطراف الازمه قائلا
ان واشنطن ملتزمه بالمساعده لتجاوز الازمه
وتحقيق مطالب ثوره الخ من يناير على حد
تعبيره عموما وحتى اشعار اخر تبقى الساحه
السياسيه المصريه متوتره بل ومفتوحه على
مهددات امنيه كثيره يخشى ان يفرزها
الاحتقان الراهن وليس ببعيد عن الاذهان
تلك الاحداث التي شهدتها مواقع مختلفه في
البلاد مؤخرا وبينها ساحه الحرس
الجمهوري ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من القاهره
عصام العبيدي نائب رئيس تحرير صحيفه الوفد
واحمد سبيع المتحدث باسم حزب الحريه
والعداله اهلا بضيفي لو بدانا بالسيد
العبيدي هل تعتقدون بان هذه الاجواء
الحاليه في مصر يمكن ان تتيح المجال
لتسويه ما
في
اعتقادي انه لكي تكون هناك تسويه او ما
يمكن تسميته مصالحه بين كافه الطوائف
السياسيه فلابد من تحقيق يعني شيئين في
منتهى الاهميه اول شيء على قاده جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين والتيار الاسلامي
السياسي التوقف عن التحريض وعمال التحريض
في
الميادين اف المناداه
بالعنف والدم
ومحاوله دفع انصارهم لمهاجمه مؤسسات
الدوله وخاصه المؤسسات العسكريه هذا من
ناحيه القوى التيار الاسلامي والاخوان
المسلمون تحديدا كما ان على الدوله ايضا
ضور لكي تتحقق المصالحه وهو محاوله ايقاف
الملاحقه الامنيه لقيادات الاخوان
المسلمين حتى على الاقل بشكل مؤقت لاتاحه
صه لام امكانيه تسويه هادئه بين الطرفين
اذا مطلوب من الطرفين القليل من التنازل
لان تشبس كل طرف برايه ووجهه نظره وعدم
التنازل يجعل عمليه المصالحه والتسويه
عمليه مستحيله لكن الواقع يقول ان الوطن
بات مهدد والمخاطر اصبحت عظيمه خاصه في ظل
اشتعال الوضع في سيناء وتفجر بشكل فجائي
بعد 30 يونيو الماضي والتهديد
بمجموعه من الاغتيالات السياسيه كما يعني
صدح بعض الشخصيات السياسيه على منصه
النهضه من ان هناك قائمه اغتيالات وسيتم
اللجوء لهذا العنف اعتقد ان هنا نقول ان
الوطن في خطر ولا بد من تهيئه المناخ
لاجراء مصالحه شامله يكون اساسها وقف
التحريض من ناحيه الاخ اخوان وايقاف
المواجهات وايقاف الملاحقات الامنيه لقاده
الاخوان وعلى سهم المرشد محمد بديع فعن
مصالحه تتم بتنازلات من الطرفين كما قلت
لك خاصه عفف اذا
اخذنا نعم سنصل الى ويليام بيرنز لكن اذا
اخذنا بموضوع التنازلات المتبادله واشرت
الى التنازلات المطلوبه من الصف الاسلامي
هنا نسال سيد احمد سبيع هل
فعلا التيار الاسلامي قادر على ضبط الامور
بشكل لا تصل في النهايه الى مواجهه مفتوحه
خاصه عندما تتهمون بالتحريض على
العنف يعني بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه
اريد ان اصحح بان الطيار الاسلامي ليس هو
صاحب زمام الامور الان هناك شعب موجود
مظاهرات في كل مكان تخرج في كل مكان الان
على شريط العاجل للجزيره مظاهرات في ميدان
رمسيس واخرى على كوبري ست اكتوبر هناك في
رابعه العدويه ايضا في ناده مصر في كل
المحافظات المصريه وبالتالي ليس ما يقرب
من حوالي 20 25 مليون مواطن مصري يتبادلون
التظاهرات والاعتصامات السلميه كلهم من
التيار الاسلامي بالتاكيد المشهد يتصدره
التيار الاسلامي ولكنه ليس صاحب القرار
خاصص وان هناك شعب هو الذي يتحرك لكي
يستعيد الدكتور محمد مرسي ويعيد له شرعيته
مره اخرى هذه من ناحيه ولكن اسمح اسمح لي
حول حول هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني اسمح لي
حول هذه النقطه حتى و لم تكونوا انتم في
صداره هذه التحركات اما زلتم قادرون على
التاثير عليها بحيث تحولون دون ان شرارها
الى
العنف انا ادعوك يا استاذ محمد وادعو
الاستاذ عصام يجيء يوم ويجالس ويسام
ويحاكي المتظاهرين سواء في ميدان ربيعه
العدويه وميدان ناض مصر ويعلم ان الجميع
رفع شعار واحد لن يتخلوا عنه هو السلميه
الرهان الموجود للمؤيدين للدكتور محمد
مرسي هو والتغيير بشكل سلمي نحن نستكمل
ثوره 25 يناير التي بدات سلميه ومازالت
تسير بشكل سلمي الان نرى هناك انقلاب واضح
جدا على الثوره واهدافها ممن كانوا يزعمون
انهم يريدون ان يغيروا ويصححه مسار هذه
الثوره بدانا نشاهد رموز واقطاب النظام
السابق يعدون لواجهه مره اخرى وبالتالي
هذا ازعج بشكل كبير كل اطياف الاطياف
السياسيه التي ترى ان هناك ازمه حقيقيه
تعتري هذا الوطن وبالتالي جاءت وانضمت ال
المتظاهرين في رايعه العدويه وغيرها
المشهد يجب ان نراه من الداخل ليس من عبر
شاشات التلفاز هناك شعار رفعناه من
البدايه حتى النهايه اول مظاهره تمت في
رابعه العدويه كانت لا للعنف واستمرينا
على هذا الحال قتل من بين من بين سفوف
المتظاهرين وهم يصون الف الفجر ما يقرب من
ست او 57 مواطن مصري ولم يت تتحرك الاحزاب
السياسيه الاخرى التي صدعتنا بحقوق
الانسان ومع ذلك المتظاهرون ما زالوا
يتعاملون بسلميه يوميا تسقط او يعني ترمى
على المتظاهرين في ميدان نهض مصر ورابعه
العدويه المنشورات التحذيريه والتحريض وال
يعني التي يمكن ان نسميها يعني بتخوف مين
وبته مين ومع ذلك الجميع يرفع شعار
السلميه من جانبنا نحن نرفع شعار السلميه
ولن نفعل شيء الا السلميه ولو كنا نتحدث
عن تعطيل مرافق كما يقول تقول قوات القوات
المسلحه او تعطيل المنشات لكانت هذه
المظاهرات في عز ذروه الظهيره ولكننا
بدانا مظاهراتنا بعد صلاه القيامه وبعد
صلاه المغرب حتى تكون المصالح الحكوميه
انتهت من اعمالها وحتى نقول للجميع هذا هو
الشعب الذي دافع عن شرعيته والذي يخاف على
مصالحه الحكوميه بينما كان الاخرون
الانقلابيون الذين قطعوا الطرق منعوا
العمل في المحافظات منعوا المحافظين من
دخول اشغالهم قطعوا المواصلات قطعوا السكك
الحديديه اقتحموا السجون يقتحموا
الاقصم سيع هنا هناك ظاهره يعني لا للنظر
وهنا اسال سيد العبيدي عنها عندما يصبح
الاحتكام للشارع هو اليه التغيير في مصر
بمعنى هذا يلجا الى الشارع والى ما يوصف
بمليوني يريد ان يغير مجرى الامور والاخر
يلجا الى نفس الاسلوب هل اصبحت الطبقه
السياسيه رهينه الشارع ورينه الناس
وتحركاتها لم تعد هناك طبقه سياسيه قادره
على التاثير في مجريات
الامور
يعني دعنا نقول ان هناك فارق كبير بين
خروج الشعب المصري في 30 يونيو الماضي
وبين ما يحدث الان في ميدان النهضه او
ميدان ربعه العدويه او اشاره ربعه العدويه
تحديدا لانها لا تعد ميدان لكنها اشاره
مرور دعنا نقول ان الجماهير عندما خرجت في
30 يونيا خرجت بارادتها ارادتها الحره
لتعبر عن سخطها وغضبها على فشل حاكم فشل
العامل كامل في تحقيق اي انجاز على ارض
الواقع بل ادخل مصر في متاهات لا حصى لها
وستعاني الاجيال القادمه لسنوات وسنوات
وسنوات من فشله خاصه في مجال نهر النيل
واقامه السدود اخي الفاضل اليوم اثيوبيه
اعلنت عن اقامه ثلاث سدود جديده
على نهر النيل اذا هناك مشاكل جمه نعم
اسمحلي انت تقول نزلت بارا ارادتها ولكن
كل شق لديه القدره على بين قوس سين تجييش
الناس 30 يونيو خرجت الناس للتعبير عن غضب
معين من القياده السياسيه السابقه هناك من
اطر ودع الى ذلك والان هناك قوى سياسيه
مؤطر و تمت دعوتها ايضا للتعبير عن وجهه
نظر بالتالي المشكله هي في اللجوء الى
الشارع كاداه للتغيير هنا
المشكل لا اخي محمد الفارق كبير كما قلت
لك واصر على ذلك ان الجماهير التي تخرج
اليوم في ربعه العدويه او نهضه مصر تحمل
حملا في الباصات والاتوبيسات توضع يعني
يعني لا ادري باي شكل يعني شيء مهين ان
يوضع بشر لهم اراده بهذا الشكل وتجر لهم
اسوا عمليه غسيل مخ ان ما جرى ما هو الا
ضد الاسلام ومحاربه للاسلام ومحاربه
للمشروع الاسلامي في حين انهم يعني ان
هؤلاء البؤساء المغرر بهم لو فاقوا اضاق
ان نظام محمد مرسي طوال عام كامل لم يقدم
للاسلام اي شيء بل انه اصبح الراعي لمصالح
اميريكا واسرائيل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ويكفي انني قلت في قناتكم الكريمه من قبل
ان اسرائيل لم تحزن على مبارك بقدر حزنها
على موتسي وراينا الولايات المتحده يعني
تتلك في الاعتراف بالثوره الشعبيه في 30
يونيو ويعني حتى الان مجرد حضور طبعا
ويليام بينز يعد اعترافا بشرعيه النظام
القائم لكن هناك يعني محاربه في امريكا
للنظام الجديد ويردون اعاده محمد مرسي مره
اخرى للحكم لكن امام صوه الشعب لابد ان
يقول الجميع تعظيم سلام اذا هناك خروج
باراده شعبيه حره كامله وهناك غسيل
للادمن بغ بغض النظر عن
الحيثيات نعم يعني اسمح لي مره اخرى على
المقاطع بغض النظر عن الحيثيات هل معنى
ذلك يعني المنطق الذي تتحدث به الان سيد
العبيدي والمنطقه الذي يتحدث به سيد احمد
سبيع يجعلنا نفهم بان امكانيه الوصول الى
نقطه التقاء معينه تكاد تكون مستحيله سيد
سبيع بص يا استاذ محمد انا اتفق مع
الاستاذ عصام عندما قال بان الفرق قبير
بالفعل الفارق كبير بين ما يحدث الان وما
حدث في 30 يونيو ما يحدث الان هو دفاع عن
الحق عن الشرعيه عن رئيس مدني منتخب انتخب
الشعب المصري بينما ما حدث في 30 يونيو هو
انقلاب عسكري خسيس و
غلف بواجهه سياسيه فاشله لم تحقق شيء في
الشارع المصري هذا هو الفرق بالفعل
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عندما يتحدث عن
وساطه او عن نقطه التقاء نقطه التقاء
الاولى ان يعود الدكتور محمد مرسي ممثل
الشرعيه الحقيقيه في مصر حتى نكون هناك
بعد ك نتحدث نقطه التقاء لكن ان يتم فرض
امر واقع ثم نقول بان هذا الامر الواقع ان
الجمير خرجت واحتشدت بينما الموجودين الان
طوال 16 يوم في عز الشمس وفي عز الحر
اليوم السادس في رمضان معتصمين او السابع
في رمضان معتصمين صائمين يعبدون ربهم
سبحانه وتعالى ليس معهم اسلحه الا الدعاء
لله سبحانه وتعالى ثم نقول بانهم مغيبون
يا اخي اذا كان نص الشارع المصري مغيب
يعني انت بتتكلم ازاي يعني اللي كانوا
موجودين يوم 30 يونيو هم اللي كانوا صاحين
ده كلام مش منطقي خلينا نتكلم الكلام بشكل
منطقي نحن قدرنا من نزل الى يوم من نزل في
30 يونيو قدرنا مطالب الناس وقلنا ان في
مشاكل والرئيس اعترف ان هناك اخطاء ويجب
ان يتم تداركها وضع خريطه طريق بيتم
تنفيذها بس اضافوا عليها عزل الرئيس الله
احنا بنتكلم في ايه تاني احنا احترمنا
الاخرين بينما الاخرين مصرون على عدم
احترام الشعب المصري في انتخابات برلمانيه
تم حلها بحكم قضائي مسيس في في استفتاء
على الدستور تم استفتاء عليه واقر الدستور
ثم يعطل الان رئيس الجمهوريه عندما فشلوا
في ايجاد اي
ظهير لشيله او لعزله قاموا بانقلاب عسكري
مجلس الشور واضح من كلامك واضح من كلامك
سيد شيع
يعني واضح من كلامك سيد سبيع ومن كلام سيد
العبيدي بان حاله الاستقطاب في الشارع
المصري ما زالت مستمره وقد تتعمق على
الارجح هناك مساعي وطنيه داخليه وهناك
مساعي خارجيه ربما من بينها زياره مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي هو ما سنتطرق اليه
بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها تطورات المشهد
السياسي حاليا في مصر سيد عبيدي قبل قليل
اشرت الى زياره ويليام
بنز الموقف الامريكي كان موقف محل انتقاد
من عديد الجهات في في مصر ان ياتي مسؤول
امريكي على هذا المستوى ويجري مباحثات مع
اطراف مصريه مختلفه ما الذي يمكن ان ان
نقوم به ان يقوم به
بالاحرى في اعتقاد ان حضور مجرد حضور
مسؤول الامريكي بهذا الشكل وتقابله مع
المسؤولين الرسميين وعلى راسهم الرئيس
المؤقت عدلي منصور والسيد الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح السيسي هو اعتراف بشرعيه ما حدث في
مصر من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
اخرى يعني محاوله
اصلاح الصوره الذهنيه السيئه التي رسمها
الشعب المصري للامريكان خلال الفتره
الماضيه نتيجه للتردد والارتباك الذي ساد
الموقف الامريكي من الثوره المصريه
فالموقف الامريكي كما راينا يحاول بقدر
الامكان ان يحافظ على السيد مرسي لاخر نفس
لديه لانه كما قلنا هو حامي امن اسرائيل
داخل مصر وداخل غزه يكفي ان نقول ان طوال
فتره محمد مرسي لحكم لم تطلق طوبه او
قذيفه من غزه على اسرائيل فكان بالنسبه
لهم يعني كنزا جديدا يعني لم يتحقق ايام
مباره
اذا حضور السيد برنز
ومحاوله دفعه جميع الاطراف السياسيه
للدخول ل مائده مفاوضات في اعتقادي انها
محاوله جيده قد تؤتي ثمارها في الايام
القادمه بشرط وقف التصعيد كما قلت من
الطرفين من جانب قيادات الاخوان المسلمين
ووقفهم على التحريض ودفع اتباعهم لمحرك و
محركه الاصدام بالجيش والهجوم على المنشات
العسكريه وهنا سيسقط ضحايا بالالاف وليس
بالعشرات كما سقط يوم الحرس الجمهوري كما
ان على النظام الحاكم الان ان يحتوي
الاخوان المسلمين يحتويهم بايقاف
للملاحقات الامنيه حاليا الا يعني حتى لو
بشكل مؤقت ومن عليه قضايا بعد ذلك يتم
التعامل معه طبقا للقانون
وبدون اي اجراءات استثنائيه اذا ما حدث مع
الرئيس محمد مرصي مثلا هو اج احترازي لكن
يمكن الان بالنسبه لقاضيه الاخوان
المسلمين وقف الملاحقه بشرط كما قلت وقف
التحريض هذا هو الارضيه المناسبه والمناخ
المناسب لعمليه التفاوض التي تبدا بين
الطرفين على الاخوان المسلمين ان يدركوا
حقيقه نهائيه انها ان نظام محمد مرسي
انتهى انتهى الى غير رجعه ولن يعود مره
اخرى حتى الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي لا
يملك السماح لمحمد مرصي بالعوده الى الحكم
لان محمد مرصي رحل بامر الجماهير خرج بامر
الشعب عندما يخرج 33 مليون مواطن اليوم
يوم 30 يون ويقولون بعد اذنك سيد سبيع هل
هل هل واشنطن والاداره الامريكيه وهنا
اسال سيد سيد
سبيع هل هل الاداره الامريكيه التي تعرضت
لنقد بسبب ما اعتبر موقف مرتبك منها او
ضبابي فيما يتعلق بما جرى في في مصر قادره
على ان تلعب دورا ما الان في مصر
يعني بدايه الاداره الامريكيه هي هذه
الاداره الامريكيه هذا هو الاسلوب
الامريكي في التعاطي مع الامور هي دعمت
الحركه الانقلابيه زيارات ان باترسون
المتعدده للاحزاب السياسيه لقائها مع
البابا توادروس لقائها مع جبهه الانقاذ
تدعيم جبهه الانقاذ منح ظهير دولي لها كما
قال الدكتور البردعي وليس احد غيره ان هو
اقنع الغرب وامريكا بقبول هذا الانقلاب
بالتالي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني
متحلف بشكل كبير جدا في هذا الانقلاب ونحن
لا نعول لا على امريكا ولا على غير امريكا
اعترافها بالحكم الانقلابي لا يضرنا ولا
ينفعنا احنا نعول على الشعب المصري الذي
بدا يعرف جيدا بان هناك ازمه حقيقيه من
هذا الحكم الانقلابي الامر الاخر الصحف
الامريكيه ب بانفس التايمز
والواشمة هو نيسي حرب غزه اللي كانت
موجوده السنه اللي فاتت دخلنا على سنه
اقرب يعني اقل من سنه في حرب غزه حرب كانت
حرب كبيره جدا لولا تدخل الرئيس محمد مرسي
بثقله الدولي لوقف لما وقف هذا الحرب وكان
كل قارده امريكا بيجوا للقاهره عشان يستجد
مص تتوسط لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه لوقف
صواريخها المتجهه الى اسرائيل الامر الاخر
من ذهب وخرج فرحا في الشوارع عندما يعني
تم هذا الانقلاب هو الشعب الاسرائيلي مش
حد ثاني فتيجي تقول لي بعد كده محمد مرسي
كان امان لاسرائيل الامر الاخر نقطه مهمه
جدا اريد ان استغل هذه الفرصه ونوضحها من
خلال شاشه الجزيره من يقول باننا نطالب
المتظاهرين بالاحتكاك بالمنشات العسكريه
او المنشات الدوله هذا لم يثبت انا عايز
اقول لحضرتك ميدان رابع العدويه يقع فيه
امام المسجد
مباشره مبنى المخابرات الحربيه يقع بجوار
المسجد الاداره العامه للمرور في خلف
المسجد الاداره العامه لامن الموانئ ما في
قلب المسجد في قلب الميدان الاداره العامه
للشؤون الماليه والاداريه للقوات المسلحه
كل هذه المبان المنشات العسكريه والمنشات
الرسميه لم يتعرض لها احد بسوء بل انها
محميه من قبل الثوار قبل ان تكون محميه من
قبل امنها وبالتالي اللعب على فكره انه لن
يعود محمد مرسي محمد مرسي جاء بصندوق وسوف
يعود مره اخرى اباره الشعب المصري وعلى
الانقلابيون ان يعودوا حساباتهم وان
يرتبوا اوراقهم جيدا لان الشعب المصري
استفاقه من غفوه مارسها الاعلام المصري
المضلل للاسف الشديد الذي يتعامل حتى ما
يحدث مع الرابعه العدويه بانه امر هامشي
رغم انه دخل اليوم ال 16س عش على التوالي
نعم السؤال الان سيد العبيدي طالما ان
الولايات المتحده متهمه من قبل هذا الطرف
ومن قبل ذاك الطرف تبقى هي مع ذلك الدوله
الوحيده التي ارسلت مسؤول لها لان الان من
يتابع ال الكتابات المصريه يجد ان هناك
مجموعه من الدول تتعرض لانتقادات عديده
الولايات المتحده تركيا قطر تونس لكن ا
الثقه الامريكي الان تعتقد بان اهتمام
امريكا بهذا الوضع يمكن ان يتوج قريبا
بصيغه تعمل على بلورتها ربما في في الفتره
المقبله يعني لا يمكن لاي منصف ان ينكر
قيمه الضوء الامريكي في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط باكملها وفي مصر تحديدا ف هم يعني
لهم يد في في مؤس سسه الحكم باي وسيله
كانت سواء كانت بال المعونه التي تدفع
للقوات المسلحه والتي تقدر ب 1.3 من مليار
دولار واغلبها يكون في صور تسليح يعني
القوات المسلحه لها علاقات قويه بالمؤسسه
العسكريه لا يمكن لاحد ان ينكرها على
الاطلاق وكلا الجانبين القوات المتحده
والمؤسسه العسكريه على حضس كامل باستمرار
هذه العلاقه وهذا الدعم المتبادل بين
الطرفين اذا الضور الامريكي موجود وينبغي
استثماره في تحقيق نوع من الدفع الاطراف ل
المصالحه لا اقول الضغط لكن دفع الاطراف
الى المصالحه وتهيئه الاجواء المناسبه
ويعني للاسف
نحن جو الانقسام الذي ساد طوال عام مضى
بفعل حكم الرئيس محمد مرسي والذي مزق
الامه تمزيقا جعل لابد من وجود طرف خارجي
يتدخل خ لحسم الامر وفي اعتقادي ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتدخلها
الفعال قد يكون تدخلها حاسما في اجراء
المصالحه عن طريق دفع الجيش ودفع الاخوان
معا ودفع كافه القوه السياسيه للجلوس على
ماعده التفاوض التفاوض على اسس عادله كما
قلنا لا ينبغي لطرف ان يصعد الى اعلى شيء
كان يقول الاخوان لابد ان يعود محمد مرصي
وان يعود الى الحكم هذا يعني حلم بعيد
المنال لا يمكن تحقيقه لاني كما قلت لك لا
عب الفتاح السيسي ولا غيره يملك ذلك لان
امر ازاحه محمد مرسي جاء من الشعب وشعب
وحده فقط هو الليمن حس الشرعيه وهو الذي
سلبها منه في الاونه الاخيره شكرا لك نائب
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الوفد المصريه عصام
العبيدي شكرا ايضا للمتحدث باسم حزب
الحريه والعداله السييد احمد سبيع بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد استودعكم
[موسيقى]
الله